i'm sahaz bharwai i'm an evolutionary
ecologist and ornithologist at the
smithsonian national museum of natural
history today i'm here to answer your
questions from twitter this is bird
support
[Music]
this question is from jay zhu how do
messenger pigeons work do they have
google maps or some patients have very
strong abilities to detect magnetic
fields but they also remember landmarks
really well a lot of homing pigeons also
have what is called magnetite in their
beaks and magnetoreceptors in their
nervous system or brains this magnetite
basically helps them to orient in the
right direction so even if they can't
see the sun if it's really cloudy and
windy and they can't orient themselves
they will know which way is north or
east or west and south uh based because
of this really cool these magnetite
particles in their beaks the next
question is from will j parker jesus why
are these geese so loud it's midnight go
to sleep geese geese can be loud for
multiple reasons when they are getting
ready to migrate they honk a lot to sort
of get their crew together in the spring
they start pairing up and they vocalize
with each other to sort of strengthen
the pair bond but they'll also then
honk together to keep other pairs of
geese away from that territory they'll
probably honk at you very loudly or even
may like run up to you or like charge
you with their wings open if you're too
close to their eggs or babies a question
from imari
wait how do birds have sex most birds
have sex by what is called cloacal
kissing birds have a
common orifice for for pooping and
peeing and basically having sex and so
first the males and females line up that
orifice and the male transfers the sperm
into the
females cloaca so that's true for most
birds but some male birds
like ostriches have
what pretty much looks like a
penis it's often called a cloacal
protuberance they insert that penis into
the females cloaker to transfer the
sperm ducks have corkscrew shaped
penises they
go into the female cloaca which is also
reverse corkscrew shaped because there
is so so many forced matings in several
duck species mallards being the most
common example females actually also
have blind alleys that don't lead up to
their ovaries and eggs
and so if the female doesn't want to
mate with a male that's sort of forcing
himself on her she can just get him to
deposit his sperm in one of these blind
alleys where his sperm will never be
able to fertilize the eggs the next
question is from broken halos how do
owls turn their heads so far around is
their spine in the center of their neck
owls have this crazy ability to turn
their heads almost up to 270 degrees
which is absolutely nuts and here's a
specimen of a northern pygmy owl that is
showing you what it's doing it's
actually turning its head completely
around and that's something that you
cannot do there are two reasons why
birds evolve the ability to do that the
first is that birds cannot move their
eyes in their own sockets so i can
follow my finger without turning my head
and that's because i can move my eyes in
my sockets birds can't do that and so
they have to move their head every time
they want to follow another object the
other reason when i turn my head all the
way to the back after a bit of time i'm
going to cut off the blood supply to my
brain it's not going to be very nice in
a few seconds because i'll probably pass
out if i keep doing that but owls have
evolved this really cool blood supply
network that actually compensates other
blood vessels take over and keep
supplying blood to the bird's brain this
bird
is also really cool because it has these
markings that look like eyes at the back
of its head a lot of owls around the
world have those markings and they are
also supposed to be an anti-predatory
strategy constantly saying hey i'm
looking at you even if they're not by
funky diabetic how do birds all know
where to go at the exact same time the
simple answer is they're just watching
their neighbors these big murmurations
of starlings that you may have seen
videos of do these really cool
formations in the air well we don't know
exactly why they do that but they are
doing what the next few birds around
them are doing so you will see a few
birds turn and that sort of wave goes
through the whole flock they are not
that coordinated as a whole flock of a
thousand birds but they coordinate with
their immediate neighbors that are
flying around them when geese or starks
fly in a v there is some thermodynamic
advantage and the bird in the front is
working the hardest and often the bird
in the front will give up and go back in
line and another bird will take its
place birds sort of coordinate who is
doing all the work when they're flying
to make everyone's energy energy use
more efficient next up from locally
stupid how do birds not get cold i feel
like they need a jacket so most birds
have a feather that is part down these
like fuzzy non-interlocking barbs that
basically catch air close to the bird's
body very similar to like mammal fur
penguins live in really cold
environments and they have extremely
dense feathers there are other birds
that live in very cold environments as
well in northern canada there are
chickadees that live in like negative 20
degrees outside and the chickadee is
like the same weight as like a couple of
teaspoons of sugar the feathers in your
down jackets come from geese and ducks
and so we have actually used their
feathers to keep us warm now next up is
a question from tony sabad say bad
what's the smartest bird i bet you it's
none of them new galilean crows are
supposedly wicked smart because they can
design their own tools and you can give
it a stick and it will make it into a
tool that it will use then to get to a
treat that you like set up for it also
birds are really smart because they can
fly from alaska to new zealand and find
the exact same spot that they found last
year try going anywhere without google
maps yourself let alone across
continents cbd elizabeth do all birds
lay unfertilized eggs the way chickens
do do wild songbirds lay empty eggs most
birds don't want to lay unfertilized
eggs because unfertilized eggs is a lot
of energy and resources some birds lay
eggs that are as much as 20 of the
bird's body there are birds that lay
unfertilized eggs but as part of a
bigger clutch of eggs off fertilized
eggs chickens that lay on fertilized
eggs have been manipulated hormonally
generally to produce eggs that are
unfertilized do wild birds wild
songbirds lay empty eggs if you mean
something like a ping pong ball then
they don't because the eggshell is
actually a covering that goes on to an
embryo so inside of the egg forms first
and the eggshell is sort of like sprayed
on
around it and then hardens they can't
just form the outside without the inside
so they don't lay empty eggs this
question is from judas clancy do bird
eyes dry out as they soar through the
sky birds have this
third
eyelash called the nictitating membrane
it's a transparent membrane so birds can
actually
use it while they're flying if you watch
a bird up close you can actually watch
them use their nictitating membrane to
wink their eye closed and shut but the
dictating membrane itself is completely
transparent and so the bird can still
keep seeing when it's doing that next
question is by decal dw do all birds
build nests most birds build nests but
several different families of birds
evolved what is called brood parasitism
where females lay eggs in another
individual's nest and that can be
another individual of the same species
or another individual of a completely
different species cuckoos for example go
and lay their eggs in the nests of other
birds those eggs generally hatch out
earlier and push out all the other
babies and then the parents end up
raising just the cuckoo chick quick
anecdote about that is that cuckoos know
that the host birds can count when they
go to lay their eggs if they find four
eggs in the nest they will lay one egg
and then take out one of the host eggs
to make sure that the host doesn't find
out that there are suddenly five eggs
when they only laid four
mistress underscore time what the [ __ ]
are emus why do they make that sound
they're literally dinosaurs wtf why the
hell is there a bird that's taller than
me this isn't fair the emu is not even
the biggest bird in the world so the
ostrich is bigger than the emu okay they
are pretty big well i'm glad you brought
up dinosaurs because birds are in fact
more close related to dinosaurs than any
other animal that ever lived on earth
why are they so big well there's a bunch
of birds ostriches emus and cassowaries
these three birds are really really big
they can be as tall as people or even
bigger they are just an ancient lineage
of birds now that you know that birds
are actually dinosaurs they're actually
pretty small right from hummus beings or
humus beings what's the loudest bird for
its size two new holland honey eaters
can make quite a racket loudest recorded
bird is a white bell bird
most of their sounds they make are above
the frequencies that we can actually
hear but they can be extremely loud
those birds can be louder than some
planes even they often use that uh to
attract mates from marty mush do birds
ever know where they're actually going
when they go south or do they keep
flying until it's warm i feel like there
aren't just like we're going to florida
pack it up well birds do know where
they're going and they'll often use the
earth's magnetism the stars and several
landscape features to direct where
they're going birds have the ability to
go across continents and find the same
patch of forest that they spent
last winter in gps trackers have shown
that some birds like the bartell godwit
fly non-stop for 12 000 miles from
alaska to new zealand and find the exact
same patch of wetland that they used the
previous winter eliza are there any
birds with teeth that's one of the weird
mysteries of bird evolution before the
dinosaurs went extinct there are a lot
of birds with teeth and then after
that there are no birds with teeth there
is no real reason why there are no birds
with teeth today none of them for some
reason survived same apocalypse that
that wiped out the dinosaurs from rain
liu 3 how do birds fly in the rain
explain it to me now birds fly in the
rain just like they fly in any other
weather bird feathers have highly water
resistant parts called the penicius part
which stops the water from actually
going in and soaking the rest of the
bird when they take a bath they can dunk
themselves in water many ducks you may
have seen on the water and they emerge
without getting wet it's because they're
like wearing a rain shell the whole time
i am reacts do birds ever fly just for
fun or are they always on some sort of a
mission just like you and me many birds
play crows and ravens will often play
and you will see them doing these really
cool like tumbling dives through through
the air crows and ravens are a good
example they will fly to have a game
with their flock mates and they will fly
around just when it's really windy or
i don't know just for the fun of it
zia xt bro how do owls not produce sound
while flying that's a great question
owls have really cool adaptations to
reduce the amount of sound they make
owls are generally nocturnal and most
animals that are nocturnal have a really
good sense of hearing i also evolved
this way to sort of cancel the amount of
noise that they're making when they're
flying from the flapping by the cool
feathers they have so the owl feathers
the ends of the barbs have like combs or
little brushes that basically break up
the air in a way that it doesn't produce
a sound when it's flying not all owls
have that but most owls have that
from at makangawini is there a shazam
for bird call you can download an app
called merlin and then record a bird
call and then merlin will help you id
and tell you what bird it is but you can
generally filter down from all the birds
that are in your field guide to just a
few species based on the size of the
bird the habitat you're seeing and where
you're seeing the bird in
on earth that's something that you learn
to do
from when you start boarding next
question is from author rkk how do birds
learn how to use tools i'm curious
several birds show tools egyptian
vultures will use giant rocks to smash
open ostrich eggs darwin's finches on
the galapagos islands we'll use little
sticks as spears to fish out
caterpillars and and beetle larvae that
are hiding underneath the bark of plants
we don't know how birds learn to use
tools they definitely watch others as
they make tools we know this from new
caledonian crows and we know this from
ravens and from kia's that they are very
very good social learners you and i
learn uh new tricks from watching
someone else do it
birds they'll watch another bird study
what the other bird is doing especially
if the tool the other bird is using ends
up in them getting a treat then they'll
definitely be very very careful about
learning that and then go try it
themselves by uber mughal curious
amateur birding question is b color
variable within species or is it a
defining character b color changes both
within species and within an individual
also european starlings will actually
change the color of their beak in the
summer than in the winter and color of
the beak is also driven by some of the
same compounds that drive the color of
feathers the variation in bird b color
within a species is often used to
identify different populations from each
other sue the t-rex ornithology question
do birds in tropical zones migrate like
they do in temperate climates how can
you tell what species will be where
throughout the year many birds will
often migrate just to find food so a lot
of birds will fly between areas with
high rainfall to areas with low rainfall
this includes a lot of birds in
australia and a lot of birds in africa
that follow the rain clouds across
the continent rain generally produces a
new flush of vegetation which produces a
new flush of insects that these birds
feed on parrots uh will follow fruiting
cycles of different species of trees
just because they know that
their favorite fruit will be fruiting in
that area how can you tell what species
will be where throughout the year your
bird guide will generally tell you
whether a bird is a year-round resident
or is found only in the winter or early
in the summer that's something for you
to find out as well you can go birding
and make a list of birds that you see at
the end of one entire calendar year of
birding you will know what birds you see
throughout the year this question comes
from dr della rocker ornithology
question do birds breed interspecies my
wife and i were talking about dogs and
mutts and we realized that we don't know
if there's a bird equivalent can an
albatross mate with a wren or something
like that two breeds of dogs even a
great dane breeding with a chihuahua is
the same species breeding with each
other an albatross and a ren probably as
distinctly related to each other as
a human and a goat are there are many
species of birds that do hybridize with
other species but those are very closely
related to each other a good example may
be a wolf and a coyote breeding with
each other that happens pretty regularly
in nature just because they're birds
doesn't mean that they can mate with
each other although closely related
species will often hybridize with each
other to produce offspring i enjoyed
answering your questions today and i
hope you learned a little more about
birds and appreciate birds a little more
happy birding
[Music]
you